the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we try to wrap up our present
discussion of partial derivatives by
means of a rather practical example
which not only has wide application but
which ties in many of the individual
principles that we've talked about in
the last two blocks of material the
particular topic that I have in mind
today is the topic known as the theory
of maxima minima of functions in several
variables you see in part 1 of our
course we studied the special case where
we had a function from the real numbers
into the real numbers and what we were
looking for were values of the
independent variable for which F was
either maximum or minimum and so a
natural extension of this as simply the
following given a for a real valued
function of several real variables in
other words assume that F is a mapping
from n-dimensional space into the real
numbers f is a function from en in to e
then the M tuple a bar in E sub n is
called a local maximum and I suppose we
might as well kill two birds with one
stone here and put in the minimum def in
the definition for a local minimum at
the same time it's called a local
maximum of F if and only if there exists
a neighborhood n of a bar such that F of
a bar is greater than or equal to f of X
bar for every X bar in the neighborhood
I suppose by the way while we're at this
for a local minimum the condition would
be what for a local minimum instead of f
of a bar being greater than or equal to
f of X bar it would be less than or
equal to in other words what you're
saying is that what you mean by a local
a local high point or low point is what
that in a neighborhood of the point in
question
for example if that output exceeds every
other possible output in a sufficiently
small neighborhood then we say that that
particular input is the local maximum
and a similar definition for local
minimum in other words again keep in
mind that
precisely and almost a word-for-word
translation of what the terms relative
maximum and relative minimum are local
maps and local men meant for functions
of a single real variable consequently
except for the fact that in several
variables it's much more difficult to
describe domains because of all the
degrees of freedom that you have one
would expect that the same particular
tests for membership would occur for
functions of several variables when
we're looking for high-low points or
maximum points as in the case of one
independent variable so let's just very
quickly summarize this how do we test
for candidates for maximum points now
the idea is simply this that if we're
going to have a relative high or a
relative low point think of the thing
graphically if you take a cross-section
with respect to any one of the
independent variables in other words if
you look at W as a function of if you
look at F as a function just of x one
say and hold X 2 up to X and constant
then when W is viewed as a function of X
1 alone then one would expect that you
have what that just in the W X 1 plane
you must have a candidate which means
that one would expect that if you took
the partial of F with respect to X 1
that must be 0 similarly the partial of
F with respect to X 2 must be 0 etc the
partial of F with respect to X sub n
must be 0 in other words to find a
candidate for a maximum point notice
that right off the bat we're back to a
practical application of the study of
systems of several equations in several
unknowns namely we must solve the
systems of equations the partial with
effort respect to X 1 equals 0 etc the
partial of F with respect to X N equals
0 find simultaneous solutions whenever
such simultaneous solutions exist now of
course there may be points in that
domain where the partials don't exist
just like there was in the case of
calculus of a single variable in other
words the second thing we do in testing
for candidates is we find points in the
domain where f is not differentiable
for example F might not be continuous F
might not be defined whatever the reason
is we look to see where F is not
differentiable and all points in the
domain at which F is not differentiable
they also become candidates for maximum
points and thirdly we check the boundary
of the domain of F in other words if the
domain of F happens to be a
two-dimensional region we check the
boundary of the region again the reason
being the same as in the calculus of a
single real variable if a function is
differentiable it must take on its
maximum and minimum value someplace if
the domain happens to be a closed set in
other words a connected set with a
boundary and we won't go into that in
any more detail at this particular time
but essentially what do we do we look at
the function wherever its differentiable
take all of its partials set them equal
to zero solve that system simultaneously
to see what values of x1 up to xn give
us permissible candidates for maximum
points we check to see where the Posche
where the derivative does not exist and
that gives us another batch of points
and then we check the boundary values to
see if anything peculiar happens there
same three tests as we had for calculus
of a single variable and why is this so
closely allied the calculus of a single
variable well if we take the case N
equals two we again get a nice geometric
interpretation namely if w is a function
of x and y notice again our notation for
what happens when we have two
independent variables they're called x
and y and usually we let the dependent
variable variable be W in that case
let's take a look and see what happens
over here suppose for the sake of
argument that we know that we have a
relative low point corresponding to the
input a comma B in other words suppose
we know that F of a comma B is the
lowest value of F the lowest height on
the surface in a sufficiently small
neighborhood of the point a comma B all
I'm saying is this take any slice
whatsoever any plane through the point a
comma B pick any direction s alright
take that plane perpendicular to the XY
plane in the
direction and sliced the surface W
equals F of XY with that plane and we
got to slice something like this not
something like this this is the slice
that we get all right now let's take a
look at where that low point is since
that is to be a low point in the entire
region obviously it must be a low point
in particular with respect to the
particular slice that we took how could
it be the lowest point every place if
it's not the lowest point with respect
to any particular slice and all we're
saying then is that with respect to this
slice notice that W is a function of S
alone in other words we can talk about
the directional derivative DFDS and
again all we're saying is that that
directional derivative the FDS evaluated
at the point a comma B must be 0 for all
directions s and as we have seen
throughout our course if F happens to be
a continuously differentiable function
of the variables x1 up to X n then the
directional derivative is determined
completely by our knowledge of the
partials with respect to x1 up to xn and
you see as far as the theory is
concerned that's all there is to it as
the cliche goes the rest is commentary
now what kind of commentary do I mean
well among other things once we have
located all the particular max min
candidates see notice why I call these
things candidates always saying is is
that wherever the system of partial
derivatives equal setting them equal to
0 yields a value that point is simply a
candidate for a maximum point just again
like in the calculus of a single
variable if f prime of a is 0 we cannot
conclude that a is a local Max or a
local min it might be a saddle point no
a stationary point where the thing just
levels off it's just once we have the
candidate how do we test whether it
really is a max or a min well what we
have to do is looking at f of a comma B
we have to see whether that's the lowest
possible value or the highest possible
value in a sufficiently small
neighborhood of that point well how do
you characterize a neighborhood
the point you look at some nearby point
which we can denote as what a plus h
comma b plus K and as this H and K seem
strange to you notice that H is often
what we call Delta X and K is what we
often call Delta Y in other words we
look at some nearby point A plus Delta X
comma B plus Delta Y and what we're
saying is that if this is to be a for
example a high point it means that when
you compute this difference this
difference had better be negative all
the time because when you look at this
particular thing over here if this is to
be the greatest possible value in a
neighborhood when you subtract it from
something else in the neighborhood you
should get a negative value in other
words to put it in still other terms
what we're saying is is that to what
Lissa's reduce again once a maximum
candidate a comma B is found we must
investigate the sign of F of a plus h
comma B plus K minus F of a B for all
sufficiently small values of H and K ok
that's for all sufficiently small values
of H and K which can be messy I don't
mean that I mean for all sufficiently
small values of H and K in other words
in a neighborhood of the point a comma B
and what I'm saying is is that this
particular computation can itself be
very messy you see this is again going
back to this idea of how we invert
equations and the like it's difficult to
compute F of a plus h comma B plus K in
general if f is a messy function if F
was a computationally complicated thing
and not only that but we may have
several unknowns more than two unknowns
and you see this was true in one
variable we saw in the case of one
variable that technically speaking to
test whether F of a was a high point or
a low point we had to look at F of a
plus h minus F of a for all sufficiently
small values of H and that could have
been a messy computation too of course
the thing that happened in a single
variable that was very helpful to us was
that in the case of a single variable we
were often able to use F double prime of
a as a hint in other words whenever F
double prime of a wasn't equal to zero
we can conclude or could conclude
whether F of a was a max R amen once we
knew that F prime of a was zero remember
that was that holding water versus
spilling water routine if F double prime
of a was positive that meant that the
curve was holding water holy water meant
that you had a minimum value if f double
prime of a was negative that meant that
the curve was spilling water and
spilling water yielded a maximum value
and the only problem was is when the
second derivative was 0 in which case
the tests failed that's when when it
means of the test failed when f double
prime of a was zero the only way we
could test to see whether a was a max or
a min or neither meaning a saddle point
was to actually look at f of a plus h
minus F of a and see what happened in
that particular case now one would like
to believe that an analogous result held
for the case of several real variables
in particular for the case of two
independent variables the point is that
in a manner of speaking it does but in
another manner of speaking things are
much more complicated than what happened
in the case of one independent variable
in particular what goes wrong is the
following and that is that the second
derivative in the case of two
independent variables involves three
separate partials see what do you mean
by a second derivative you mean you must
differentiate something twice well you
could have differentiated the function
twice with respect to X at the point a
comma B that's what we mean by F sub xx
recall or you might have differentiated
first with respect to X and then with
respect to Y in which case it would have
been F sub XY are very common B in fact
I should be careful here there should be
a fourth one here too and that is f sub
YX namely first differentiate with
respect to Y and then with respect to X
the reason I left that out over here was
simply because if we have a nice
function meaning one that's continuous
it and the derivatives are continuous
and the mixed derivatives exist in are
continuous we showed that the order in
which we take the partials
no difference that F sub XY was equal to
F sub YX but getting back to this idea
the third possibility is that you could
have differentiated twice with respect
to Y and formed F sub YY of a comma B
and so the question is with all of these
different second-order partial
derivatives floating around what do you
mean by the second partial derivative
and the key expression and I think this
is far from intuitive but the key
expression turns out to be that the
determining factor is the second part
the second partial with respect to X in
other words F sub xx x the second
partial with respect to Y F sub YY minus
the square of the mixed partial and that
particular factor the sine of that
factor determines whether you have a
maximum point a minimum point a saddle
point or else the test might fail by the
way this is a rather difficult proof to
come by the proof is done in chapter 18
of the Thomas text and is assigned for
you I try to give you learning exercises
that take you through the proof step by
step and I have also included an
optional supplementary lecture for those
of you who may still have difficulty
following both the text and the
supplementary notes and the learning
exercises because it's all written out
and might like to hear the things spoken
what I will do is derive this for you in
an optional lecture for those of you who
want it but for the time being to give
us our overview let me simply state what
the properties of this particular
quantity are that the main result and as
I just write here to remind you that the
details of the arrive later both in the
text in the learning exercises and an
optional lecture that suppose we have
solved our simultaneous system and have
found values points a comma B where the
partial of F with respect to X and the
partial of f with respect to y equals
zero so we now have a candidate meaning
a comma B now is eligible to be tested
to see whether it yields a maximum or a
minimum value the test turns out to be
this you compute
F sub X X times F sub YY minus F sub X Y
squared at the point a comma B and if
that particular number turns out to be
greater than zero then a comma B yields
a local minimum of F if the if F sub xx
happens to be positive and a local
maximum if F sub xx happens to be
negative now the easiest way to remember
that is to think in terms of a partial
derivative again imagine that we've
sliced the surface so that we're looking
at a cut in the WX plane in the WX plane
notice that if the part if the
derivative of W if the second derivative
of W with respect to X is positive that
means that the curve is holding water
and holding water seems to indicate a
minimum you see and similarly if it's
negative it's spilling water and that
would indicate a maximum you might say
what happens if F sub xx happens to be 0
and the answer is look at if F sub xx
happens to be 0 this case couldn't have
occurred in the first place because if F
sub xx happened to be 0 this term drops
out in which case this could not be a
negative this could not be a positive
expression with this term missing the
smallest the square can be is 0 and the
negative of a nonzero number can't be a
positive or nonzero number can't be
negative in other words you could not
obey this inequality if F sub xx happens
to be 0 if you want to argue why
couldn't you look at F sub YY instead of
F sub xx the answer is f sub X X and F
sub YY
must both have the same sign because if
you just look at this thing notice that
this term has to be positive you're
subtracting off something positive
therefore the term you're subtracting
from must be positive and the only way
the product of two numbers can be
positive is if each of the factors has
the same sign but again I don't want to
be late with that I just want to go
through this thing fairly rapidly with
you it turns out by the way if the
key factor this key term F sub xx F sub
YY minus the square of the mixed partial
happens to be negative then you can be
sure that you have a saddle point in
other words what that means is for any
neighborhood of the point a comma B for
some values of F for some values of X
comma Y in that neighborhood the
function will be greater than f of a
comma B and for others it will be less
than F of a comma B so it's neither a
max or a min and it turns out that the
situation in which the test fails is if
this particular expression happens to
equal zero so again you see that from a
purely mechanical point of view this
test is rather easy to memorize the hard
part is the proof and that's why as I
say there's extra drill on that part if
you happen to be interested in that and
by the way if you're not interested in
it skip the proof in fact I am for the
sake of this course I am NOT concerned
with how well you handle max-min
problems I am interested more in showing
you overall what max-min problems mean
and how all of the principles of partial
differentiation seem to come up in that
particular application of max-min
problems all right so from a theoretical
point of view that would complete the
study of how one handles maximun
problems except that an even more
difficult and subtle form of
computational difficulty comes up in
terms of some of the practical
applications that we have which motivate
such mechanical and computational
devices known as for example a little
Grange multipliers and things of this
sort that again are discussed in the
text and in the learning exercises and
which I will not discuss in the lecture
out of them to motivate for you why they
occur and let me just finish up today's
lesson in terms of one more topic and
this is a bad name for this topic
because we've already used this word in
a different context but this very often
happens in mathematics that the same
word is used in more than one context
but one often talks about constraints
when one deals with functions of several
variables
in other words in many cases when one
wants to maximize or minimize a function
of several variables it turns out that
certain external conditions happen to be
imposed now if that sounds like a
difficult mouthful to comprehend I would
like to start off with an example that's
already occurred in a maximin problem in
part one of our course but in such a
subtle way that we never noticed that it
was really involving a function of
several variables in fact if it hadn't
have been that subtle we'd have been in
trouble because in part one of our
course we did not talk about functions
of more than one real variable but for
example let's look at our revisit a type
of problem that says let's find the
minimum distance say from the origin
zero comma zero the minimum distance
from the origin to the curve XY equals 1
well to find that minimum distance
notice that what we have to do is
minimize a distance function namely the
square of the distance I use the square
simply to eliminate the square root sign
here
the square of the distance from the
origin to any point X comma Y is x
squared plus y squared well notice that
in this form this is a function of two
independent variables the trouble is you
don't want the distance from the origin
to any old point the point that you're
investigating has to be on the curve XY
equals 1 and that means that x and y for
your investigation in this problem are
not independent namely x and y are
related now by the way sometimes this
equation can be so messy that we cannot
solve for y explicitly in terms of X in
this particular case as long as X is not
0 we can solve specifically for Y in
terms of X in which case we get y equals
1 over X and that is in this particular
case then the function that we want to
minimize even though it looks like a
function of two independent variables is
really a function of one independent
variable because since Y is equal to 1
over X in our investigation f of X comma
Y is really f of X comma 1 over X in
other words going back to when F is
explicitly in this case f of X comma Y
is just X square
plus one over X quantity squared and
that in turn is also just a function of
X now you see what makes this thing more
difficult is first of all we may not be
dealing with a function of just two
variables to minimize and secondly we
may have a very difficult constraint
imposed or what makes things even more
difficult is that if we have to minimize
a function say or five variables there
may be two or three or even four
constraints imposed and the question is
how do you maximize or minimize a
function taking into consideration the
fact that there are constraints imposed
and this is what brings up all of the
type of material that I gave you as
exercises in the last unit where we
talked about the Jacobian matrix and
handled the inverting systems and how we
could solve explicitly or implicitly for
functions implicit function theorem x'
things that we talked about in those
exercise all of those things come up in
solving max-min problems and several
unknowns C more generally what we're
saying is we have more variables than
two and we have more implicit
constraints meaning more constraints
than just a single constraint and also
using more variables and also more
involving modifying implicit that you
just can't solve for one of the
variables explicitly in terms of the
other even though there is an implicit
relationship involved now I hate to work
abstractly in general but in this
particular lecture I'm going to do that
I'm going to talk with you abstractly
here but all of the exercises will deal
with concrete situations so that you'll
see all of the theory come alive in the
problems but because I want to give you
the material as compactly as possible
let me just state what the situation is
for example suppose we want to maximize
or minimize a function of what appears
to be three independent variables say f
of X Y Z and all of a sudden somebody
tells us hey in the domain that we're
interested in x y&z are not independent
there's a certain constraint and let's
write that symbolically as some function
of XY and Z equals 0
remember that's simply our apps tree
way of saying that there is some
functional relationship that relates XY
and Z and we'll simply call that G of XY
Z equals zero maybe I could solve for Z
explicitly in terms of X and Y from this
particular relationship maybe I can't
but at any rate what we do know from the
learning exercises of last time that G
of XY Z equals 0 will implicitly define
Z as some function of x and y say K of
XY except in that case where the partial
of G with respect to Z happens to be 0
and I put this thing in parenthesis for
you simply to give you motivation to
review the exercises of last time if
this seems a bit vague to you at any
rate what what this thing means in plain
English is that subject to the
constraint that Z is some function of x
and y we take this constraint we put
that back into our original function
that we're trying to minimize in other
words notice our maximized notice that f
of X Y Z now becomes f of X Y K of X Y
cz is K of X Y if we now look at this
expression notice that only x and y
appear so that subjected to the
constraint G of X Y Z equals 0 the
function f is a function of only two
independent variables not three and to
indicate that let's simply say that f of
X Y Z f of XY K of X Y in this case is
some function H of X and Y and what our
problem is now saying is minimize or
maximize the function H which is a
function of two independent variables
now notice here it's been quite a while
since we've dealt with the chain rule
but notice here that the chain rule now
comes up in a very important practical
application namely this looks like a
nice or f of X Y comma K of X Y how can
we handle that notice that another way
of saying this utilizing the chain rule
is to say H of X Y is f of X Y Z where Z
is some function K of x and y CF is a
function of XY and Z and Z is a
of X&Y in fact if you wanted to say it
another way you could say what F is some
function of XYZ where x equals x y
equals y and z equals K of X Y you see
that's your particular chain rule now
look at see this is again one of the
problems of mathematics which I hope is
crystal clear by this time granted that
we discussed the chain rule in block 3
that's no reason why in block 4 we can
beg off and say we had that a long time
ago I don't remember that no hopefully
we've made the chain rule so clear that
any time I tell you that we have to
invoke it you can just write it down
very very quickly how does the chain
rule work now to differentiate this with
respect with respect to X say we take
the partial of this with respect to x
times the partial of X with respect to X
plus the partial of F with respect to Y
times the partial of Y with respect to X
plus the partial of F with respect to Z
times the partial of Z with respect to X
in other words the general theory hasn't
changed at all to maximize or minimize H
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the partial of H with respect to X
and set that equal to 0 we're going to
take the partial of H with respect to Y
and set that equal to 0 and solve that
system simultaneously but the hardpoint
computationally is sure you can say
let's set the partial is equal to 0 but
before you can do that you had better be
able to take the partials and that's
where the computational skill comes in
so how do we take the partial of H with
respect to X here well we just said that
the partial of H with respect to X using
the chain rule is f sub x times the
partial of X with respect to X plus
that's sub Y times the partial of Y with
respect to X plus F sub Z times the
partial of Z with respect to X now
notice that the partial of X with
respect to X is 1 so that gives me F sub
X over here keep in mind that whereas Z
is a function of x and y let's go back
here and take a quick look at that
notice that in our function H we're
assuming what that x and y are the
independent variables but that Z is a
function of x and y the point therefore
is that since X and
why are independent variables by
definition that means that the partial
of Y with respect to X is zero in other
words the fact that Y and X are
independent means that the change in Y
with respect to a change in X is zero
because we can change X without changing
Y and finally given that Z is K of X Y
we can compute the partial of Z with
respect to X and so what we wind up with
is that the partial of H with respect to
X is the partial of F with respect to X
plus the partial of F with respect to Z
times the plus the partial of F with
respect to Z times the partial of Z with
respect to X and we must set that equal
to 0 again leaving the details to you as
a review of the chain rule in a similar
way we show that the partial of H with
respect to Y is the partial of F with
respect to Y plus the partial of F with
respect to Z times the possible Z with
respect to X and we set that equal to 0
now the thing to keep in mind is to
observe that f of X Y Z was a given
function we know what that looks like
consequently these four quantities are
known the trouble is that G of X Y Z
equals zero define Z implicitly as a
function of x and y and consequently if
it turned out that we could not have
solved our system for Z explicitly in
terms of x and y the question mark would
be for example I'm sorry this is a
misprint over here this should be of
course the partial of with
differentiating respect to Y this is the
partial of F with respect to Y plus the
partial of F with respect to Z times the
partial of Z with respect to Y the the
key point over here is simply that we
must know what if we can solve for Z
explicitly in terms of X and y how do we
know what these two quantities are we
only know them implicitly and this gives
us our review again of setting
differentials equal to zero and the like
namely if G of XY Z is identically 0 we
can equate the derivative on both sides
to 0 and to differentiate this thing
implicitly it's again using the chain
rule we get what the partial of G
expect to X plus the partial of G with
respect to Z times the partial of Z with
respect to X is zero notice by the way
that G is given explicitly we're told
what the function G of XY Z looks like
consequently these things here are known
alright and we can now solve for the
partial of Z with respect to X in fact
what is the partial of Z with respect to
X that's nothing more than what it's
minus the partial of Z with respect to X
divided by the partial of G with respect
to Z and that's why the partial of G
with respect to Z had better not be zero
otherwise we wind up in trouble here
similarly we can find what the partial
of Z with respect to Y is that's going
to have to be what minus the partial of
G with respect to Y divided by the
partial of G with respect to Z knowing
what these two values are from these two
equations we come back into here and now
we know what these are and now we simply
have all of known functions on the right
hand side and we solve this system now
hopefully this is one of the times I
hope things don't sound too clear to you
meaning you have an overview but you
begin to suspect that this is a very
messy situation because you see what I
want you to see is that solving such a
system like this can be extremely
cumbersome and that's why in the
exercises we do two things we have you
solve systems like this to get the
experience of seeing that it's a big
difference between knowing theoretically
how to solve a system equal of equations
and knowing pragmatically how to carry
it out and secondly we hope that some of
these computations become cumbersome
enough so that you practically beg to
find some shortcuts because if you're
not begging to find the shortcut then
such things as Lagrange multipliers and
the like which are techniques for
solving max-min problems subject to
constraints that those shortcuts don't
appeal to you and you fail to see their
significance and you say why do I have
to learn these things don't I have
enough problems without it you see again
notice the difference between what's
happening
here abstractly and what's happening
computationally abstractly the theory of
Max min is not that difficult but
computationally to handle it you have to
be extremely adept at handling systems
of n equations and n unknowns not
necessarily linear equations being able
to throw in constraints and seeing
what's happening here and at any rate
that's what the ruling exercises will be
all about and the material in the text
and I think that's enough of a mouthful
for this time so until next time good
bye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate